The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So this
is a really, really,
really, really stunning
fact in a sense of we
talk about lots of forms of
inequality and unfairness
in the world.
But here's a fact that's really
quite, quite, quite striking.
You start from the
basic, just the fact.
It's the fact that if you look
at the ratio of men and women
in the population, most
countries in the world
have many more women than men.
This is mostly because women
are just better designed,
it turns out.
When men get to the
age of about 60,
various bad things
happen to them.
In particular, their
arteries seem to harden.
And lots of them die from
various cardiovascular
diseases.
So as a result, most countries
have many more women than men.
So the ratios up
there, Europe has 1.05.
Sub-Saharan Africa has 1.02.
All of Latin America is above 1.
The US is about 1.
And while it doesn't look like a
lot, 4%, we're talking about 4%
of 3 billion.
So that's a fair number of
extra women we're talking about.
The world has many more
women than men overall.
But the one place
where that's not true
is in this belt which goes
from basically North Africa
to Korea.
That's that one belt in the
world pretty much all the way.
You can draw a belt starting
somewhere in Morocco
and keep going east,
about at that latitude.
And then go a bit
north into China,
and you'll find
that that's where
they are about 4% or
less women than men.
These numbers are not
necessarily the worst numbers
you're going to see.
So I'll show you some more
striking numbers in a minute.
I mean, just the fact
that there's 6% less women
than men is striking,
given that that doesn't
look like the biological model.
So Amartya Sen, who was a
Nobel Prize winner at Harvard
did this calculation, basically
very simple calculation.
He said, look,
Sub-Saharan Africa
is the poorest
part of the world.
So if there is some maybe
institutional reason why women
die, so there might be
reasons why women die
that have to do with poverty.
What's an example of a
reason, which would hurt women
more than men,
reason why poverty
would hurt women more than men?
AUDIENCE: During childbirth.
PROFESSOR: Childbirth, the
obvious one is childbirth.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: And then
compounding upon that,
if women in poor situations have
less access to contraceptives
and have more children, which
increases the lack [INAUDIBLE]..
There will be complications
for [INAUDIBLE]..
PROFESSOR: So everything
to do with childbirth
is reason why you might
think that in poor countries,
women will have a disadvantage.
You do see evidence
of the disadvantage.
Sub-Saharan Africa has
less women than Europe.
So you do see an example
of that disadvantage.
It's about 2 percentage
points or 3 percentage points
less women than Europe.
If you think of Sub-Saharan
Africa as the part of the world
which has the highest
maternal mortality rates.
It's the part of the world
which has the highest fertility
rates.
Both to your point
and your point,
if you take the part of
the world where women
are most likely to
die in childbirth,
and the place where women
have the most children,
both of those are highest
in Sub-Saharan Africa.
So you could think
of this as being
a reasonable approximation
of the worst case scenario.
Take the worst case scenario
and then go to China.
So that's the exercise.
Let's take the
worst case scenario.
Now go to China and
ask, if we applied
the Sub-Saharan African ratio
to the Chinese population,
how many more women
would they have had?
The answer is they would have
had 44 million more women.
So 44 million more
women are missing.
And you keep doing that,
and same order of magnitude
in India, and then smaller
countries, so smaller numbers,
but it all adds up
toward 100 million.
So you get about 100 million
missing women in the world
by doing this simple exercise.
And that's sort of
prima facie evidence.
As we'll see, you have to
think harder about exactly
what this evidence means.
This is prima facie evidence
of something very bizarre
happening.
We'll see what's going on here.
But there's something very
troubling about this fact.
Because it seems like
somehow populations
are managing to
get rid of women,
quote unquote, "losing
women" through mechanisms
which are not the normal
biological mechanisms.
So that's the missing women.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So this order
for killing women in China,
are they missing in rural China?
Or is it just all around China?
PROFESSOR: I'll show
you in a minute.
I'll show you all kinds of
facts about China, in fact.
So before I come
to that, there's
just some hypotheses
you might have.
One is, is development
the answer?
Maybe there's some
reason why just
being undeveloped for reasons
we don't understand translates
into less women.
Maybe we have a theory
that maybe it's the case
that people are more
traditional, something.
Now what makes this
fact much more worrying
is that development is not
making this fact go away.
That's sort of at least
within modern history.
We don't know what
happened 100 years ago.
But right now, development is
not making this fact go away.
If you look at the sex ratio
in India, it's not changing.
It's in fact pretty much steady.
I'll show you
numbers in a minute.
If you look at the sex ratio
in China, it's falling.
It's less and less women
every year in China.
And if you look at the
richest parts of China
versus the poorest
part to your question,
you see a negative correlation.
The riches parts of
China are the ones
which have the least women.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Do we know
anything about missing men?
Maybe there's some
component where there's just
a general [INAUDIBLE]
for children
in some parts of the world.
And the number of
children in total
are missing, not just the girls.
PROFESSOR: That's
a good question.
I think that's what
people do when they say,
the infant mortality rate
is too high or something.
And I think that
that's also a concern.
It's not that there aren't
other concerns because of this.
A lot of people would say
that you shouldn't just
look at GDP to measure welfare.
Emphasize infant
mortality rates.
Infant mortality
rates is exactly
the question you're asking,
missing boys and girls.
That number is very high
in Sub-Saharan Africa.
Sub-Saharan Africa has the
highest infant mortality
rate in the world by far.
China has now infant
mortality rates which
are approaching that in the US.
So infant morality rates
by itself, by now it's
not a huge problem in China.
China is down to
the range where it's
very, very close to the US.
I think it has infant mortality
rates of like 25 our of 1,000,
1,000 live births.
US has 18 or 14 or something.
It's really in the range, where
Sub-Saharan Africa, Sierra
Leone has 140.
So if you want to see where
infant mortality is a problem,
that's not where missing
women is a problem.
These are different problems.
It's not to say
you're not right.
That's another problem.
But it's a different one.
So this is sort of just
to show you that fact.
So what I showed you
so far was the levels,
how many women per men.
This is, in 2005,
what's the future.
Future's much more
scary than the present.
The present is what--
there was like 95
girls per 100 boys.
So that's about 105
boys per 100 girls.
That's the current.
The future, look at the
number for Eastern Asia.
That number is 120
boys for 100 girls.
It's a completely different
order of magnitude.
Think of the future.
These are the kids who
are being born under five.
So at point, if this
is what stays steady,
we are going to see numbers
more like 120 than 105.
Right now there are 105
boys to 100 girls in China.
And that number is going
to go up to closer to 120
as this cohort ages.
So that's just backing up
the first claim I made,
which is it's not
getting better.
If you look at the number
for India, it's 108.
108 is bigger than the current
ratio of men to women in India.
So current ratio is about
106, and that's 108.
So all of these countries, which
are getting richer, their ratio
is getting worse.
Do you see what this
is, how it this is
different from the one
I showed you before?
This is the ratio
among under fives.
So these are the future
of the population,
whereas I showed you the
present of the population.
Future's worse, not better.
Korea has the same kind of
numbers, which are worse.
Interestingly,
Afghanistan and Nepal,
which are relatively
poor countries,
are not getting rich
very fast, actually
you don't see much of a change.
They're about where they were.
Under five is about what they
are in the adult population.
So that suggests that
they aren't getting worse.
It's the richer countries
that are getting
richer are getting worse.
Yep?
AUDIENCE: But wouldn't
you expect this number
to be higher than the
overall population
because women are more likely
to live longer and more
[INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's
absolutely true.
So 121 go to 120.
120 is going to go to 115.
That's about the difference.
So 120 is going to do 115 of 14.
But 114 is a lot worse than 106.
All of the trends are bad.
Just to understand,
this is a big problem.
And it's not one that's
getting solved on its own
as far as I can tell.
So here's another
way to look at it.
So this is India and China.
Give yourself a few
minutes to look at this.
So the darkest areas
are the worst areas.
Does anybody know which are
the richer areas of China?
AUDIENCE: The black areas?
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it's pretty
much exactly the same.
I think Shanghai is that
gray area right there,
which is actually doing
surprisingly well.
The really poor areas of China
are those very light areas
in the west.
That's the Gobi Desert,
the Taklamakan Desert,
the Chinkiang.
All the areas with large Muslim
populations are in the east.
These are the poorest
parts of China,
and they're the ones which
are doing by far the best.
The areas that are being really
badly are the most prosperous.
The dark areas in
the southeast, that's
like Guangdong, and
Guangzhou, and all these
really fast-growing,
wealthy provinces
of China, that's the southeast.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So I'm not
really sure exactly how
[INAUDIBLE],, but
the fact that there
is [INAUDIBLE] in the number
of kids that couples can have.
You know, people might
be deciding on purpose
to have boys because they
want boys for whatever reason.
And maybe the people who
make those decision are
people to have more money,
because to have abortions
is expensive.
PROFESSOR: I think that
has a lot to do with it.
We'll come back to it.
You're perfectly right
that a lot of this ease
has something to do with
people's active choices also.
I'll come back to
that in a little.
As China gets even richer,
because this is the trend,
and it's a worrying
trend, let's say.
Now look at India.
Again, do you know what those
relatively pale areas are?
AUDIENCE: South India?
PROFESSOR: The
South India, which
is relatively prosperous
and well-educated,
and East India which is
the poorest and the most
backward part of India.
Richest state in India,
large state in India,
is Maharashtra, which is
kind of the striped state.
Let's see, on the
west coast, if you
go from the south on the west
coast, the first striped one,
that's Maharashtra.
That's the richest.
The second richest large
state is Punjab And Punjab
is that piece of black
that's right in the north.
So that's literally the second
richest, and still recently
the richest state in India,
is that area in black.
So again, the same pattern--
rich states have worse
outcomes, not better outcomes.
And there's no evidence
of a positive correlation
between income and
the gender ratio.
AUDIENCE: Is Punjab the
only state in India that has
a different religion than
the rest of the others?
Or would that be a reason?
PROFESSOR: Maybe.
What that is is there's
really two states there.
There is Punjab and Haryana.
They used to be both
a part of Punjab.
Now they've been split into
two states for some years.
But one of those states
is Sikh majority.
Sikh is a particular
other religion.
The other is Hindu majority.
There's no difference.
Actually, Haryana's
slightly worse that Punjab.
Delhi City is one of the worst
places, actually, in India.
So that's one of the
absolutely riches places.
So basically no evidence
of a positive correlation
between income and
the gender ratio--
gender ratio, if anything,
gets worse as you get richer,
for reasons that may
very be close to what
you're suggesting.
But it's clear that you get
this rather dismal pattern.
Here's something else, another
fact about sort of China.
And it's sort of a very
long term view of China.
This starts in 1920.
And you can see that basically
from the 1920s the excess sex
ratio, which is in the
five-year birth cohort.
So people who were born
in that year, what's
the fraction of
boys versus girls?
So it used to be about
7% more boys than girls.
Then it went up to about
16% during the years
when there's a lot of
political instability.
So if you think of those
years as Japanese invasion,
before that and after that, in
a sense, China is in civil war.
What are called the warlords
are fighting each other
through China.
So during wars, you see
this ratio going way up.
Then it comes in down, down,
down, down, down, down, down,
down, till about
1976 or something.
Now right around 1976
something else happens.
China introduces what's
called the one child policy.
The one child policy is one
where at least in the richer
areas, where it was the
only place it was enforced,
families were allowed to
have only one child at most.
Then that policy gets
implemented in the mid '70s.
And you see what's
happened since.
What's striking is it doesn't
just go up and stay up.
It keeps going up.
So there's something else
going on on top of the fact
that the one child
policy gets instituted.
In fact, over time, the one
child policy has been relaxed.
And this reflects some of
the tests of the population
clearly.
Families which had one
daughter in some areas
were allowed to have a son
or have a second child more
recently.
So there's some attempt
to relax the policy
in exactly the direction
that suggests that there's
a preference for boys.
But with all that,
the trend has been up.
Yep?
AUDIENCE: Do you know what's
happened to those policies?
Were they implemented,
[INAUDIBLE] relaxation?
PROFESSOR: A bunch to
the relaxations happen.
You see they're
flattening in about 1982.
That's the first relaxation.
So you do see a flattening,
but the trend is bad.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Even if it's
being relaxed, just
being relaxed, if the
first kid that you have
is a girl, and
then in that case,
you might then
try to have a boy?
But if they had
the boy right away,
maybe they'd just
stop having kids.
PROFESSOR: Absolutely.
Actually, let's take it.
So could this be generated
by a stopping rule?
So imagine that families have
a stopping rule which says,
we will stop when we
have the first boy.
This is their stopping rule.
This is a plausible
stopping rule.
My mother has one brother
and three sisters.
The brother's the youngest.
So that's not an
implausible stopping rule.
My mother's only brother has
three daughters and once son.
The son is the youngest.
It's not an implausible
stopping rule.
However, imagine we
had this stopping rule.
But in any but, the probability
of boy and girl would equal.
What would be the
population sex ratio?
AUDIENCE: Still the same.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
boys, right?
No, you'd have more women.
AUDIENCE: No, it's half.
PROFESSOR: Which one?
AUDIENCE: If you keep having
children when you have women,
then you stop as soon
as you have one boy,
you'd have more women, or
you would expect more women.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
You stop immediately.
You stop immediately
if you have one son.
[INAUDIBLE]
There might be a
family where there
are more girls [INAUDIBLE].
But most families
will stop there.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: So do you think
they'll be more [INAUDIBLE]??
AUDIENCE: I think it
pretty much evens out.
AUDIENCE: I think there will
be more boys, because if you
have a boy, you just stop.
So then that family
just has a boy.
And if you have a girl
and then you try again,
if you have a boy,
then right now
you have one family with
one boy and another family
with a girl and a boy.
But there's still
more boys than girls.
So whenever you get
to a boy, you stop.
PROFESSOR: You want
to come back to that?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, and so if we
just do an expected values,
and you get half.
Half the cases
you'll have one boy.
What are the cases
of girl and boy?
PROFESSOR: You're exactly right.
The answer is it
doesn't change anything.
And it's very simple to see.
The reason why it doesn't
change anything is very simple.
Which is that every but has
a 50% chance of having a boy.
So just take the number buts.
Forget about families.
There's a certain
number of buts.
Let's say 50 million buts.
25 million of those
buts will be boys.
And 25 million of those
buts with be girls.
It doesn't matter which
family it happens.
Every but is a separate,
independent event
and has a 50% chance
of being a boy.
So paradoxical as it
sounds, stopping girls
don't change the sex ratio.
They change the distribution.
Now here's what might be going
on, which is more complication.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: But again, but
the relaxation is now there.
Like, it's completely relaxed.
So then you can have it.
So it won't be true if you can
have as many kids as possible.
This is going to make
a difference, though,
if you have to stall--
PROFESSOR: As long as you don't
determine the sex of the child
directly, it doesn't matter.
Every but is an
independent event
with a 50% chance
of being a boy.
So take the number of
bus, multiply it by 50%,
you're going to get the number.
So it makes no difference.
Now let's think of one more
step in the [INAUDIBLE]..
Which families would a
lot of girls grow up in?
Would they have more
children or less children?
Would girls grow up on
average in a family with more
children or less children?
AUDIENCE: More children.
PROFESSOR: More children.
So if you think that families
that have more children
have less resources, then
you have a stopping rule,
then girls would be
growing up in families
with more children, and
therefore less resources.
And therefore, a
stopping rule can
have an effect on
child outcomes,
because it leads to girls
all living in large families
and boys all living
in small families.
So boys get all the attention,
the parent, the resources.
The seven girls and one
boy in the girl families,
and therefore the girls end up
with getting less resources.
So that's one
possible reason why
you might get this
outcome, because it
has something to do
with the stopping rule,
but not directly.
It has to do with the
stopping rule then
generates an allocation
of girls across families.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: So that's also true.
But If you think of about
even with the relaxation,
imagine a family in
a rich area where
everything's more expensive.
Let's say even if it was
a little more relaxed,
they still limit
themselves to say,
OK, we're going to have
a maximum of two kids.
So let's say, yeah,
maybe the first kid
that they have is a
girl, but then they say,
the probability of having
a girl for the next one,
maybe it's not really
50%, because they say,
well, we're only going to
have this kid if it's a boy.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, so what you're
saying is completely right.
The only way you
get away from 50-50
is by deliberately or
at least doing something
to the girl that
makes her not live.
That's the only
way you get there.
If the girls who are
born live, then you
can't get away from this.
It doesn't matter what
your stopping rule is.
Even if the government
makes complicated policies,
the policies don't change that.
Every but is either
a boy or girl.
So here's the last fact
I wanted you to see,
which is that if you look at
these sex ratios in India,
they're getting worse.
They got worse for a
while, now they have
stabilized at a low number.
So in 1900, there were 972
girls for boys, men for women,
women for men.
Now there are 933.
In India, you don't see a
trend after 1971 or 1981.
But the historical
trend is very negative.
So that brings us to
sort of the question.
Before we get to
policy, in a sense
we need to know what's going on.
What's going on-- there
are two possible answers.
One is kind of tradition,
and the other is economics.
So one is there's
a set of traditions
which make bad things happen.
But people are not
willing them to happen.
The other is that people
are actually making choices
to make these things happen.
So what we're going to
spend some time doing
is trying to distinguish
between these two views.
Is it tradition?
Is it economics?
So you could imagine
just traditionally
there's a theory which says
that girls need less food.
That's false.
But you believe it.
And you don't actually actively
do anything to make them die.
You have wrong beliefs.
You think girls need less
food, because adult women
are smaller than adult men.
And so you feed your girls less.
This is not an attempt to kill
them, it's just a tradition.
But then that could feed
back and have a consequence.
Problem is how do you test this?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: If you actually
look at fertility rates,
so if the number of
people that are born
are essentially all 50-50,
but then within five years
you would see a
clear difference.
So maybe at some point
that's happening.
But even if in turns of birth
rate, if there's a difference,
then it's something else.
PROFESSOR: So one
answer to this question
is if these guys are
not getting born,
then obviously something
else is going on.
Now mostly still about
five years, not five,
15 years ago, you don't see
a big trend in birthrates.
Now you actually see a
trend in birthrates as well,
reported butts they're
more and more reported
boys relative to girls.
But over 15 years ago,
you don't see that.
What you did see was more
different mortality rates
for boys and girls.
So imagine that you
wanted to test this view.
Well the problem is
how do you test it?
You don't actually observe
who eats what in a family.
So it's hard to imagine you
going and figuring out oh,
they're not feeding
their daughter.
They're feeding their son.
That's just too difficult to
do, because everybody eats out
of the same cooked food.
And so it's going to
be very hard to find.
Somebody had a very good
idea of how to do it.
We just looked at specialized
adult goods, like cigarettes.
Your daughter, a
five-year-old daughter,
doesn't smoke a cigarette, nor
does your five-year-old son.
So when a son is
born, if there's
an effect on how
much smoking you do,
it has nothing to do with the
children, the children smoking.
So children are not going to
be a direct source of demand.
So why is that good?
Because then you
can look at what
happens to smoking when the
family gets a boy or a girl.
And if girls are fed less,
what would you expect?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
They would smoke more cigarettes
because they have a larger
share of their budget
to spend on cigarettes,
because they'll give
less to the girl.
PROFESSOR: Right, smoking
goes down by less.
So the basic observation
you should see
is when a child is born,
adult income goes down,
because adults have less
money to spend on themselves,
because they will
feed the child.
But if they feed the
girl less than the boy,
then you'd see that
when a boy is born,
they'll really cut
back on cigarettes.
But when a girl is born,
they'll cut back less.
Because they are
feeding the girl less.
We have a pretty
precise measurement
of demand for adult goods.
So we can use that.
We don't know who smokes.
But we know that the kids
are not doing the smoking.
So therefore, we
can by observing
what happens to a family
when the child is born.
We can back out
whether or not there
is a difference in the way
you feed boys or girls.
Is that clear why that's
better than trying to measure?
It's very hard to
measure who eats what.
But clearly the kids
don't smoke cigarettes.
And they don't drink alcohol.
So if you look at
alcohol, and cigarettes,
and a few other things that
are essentially adult goods,
we should be able to
back out what's happening
when the child is born.
Somebody did that.
So take beverages.
Beverages doesn't include milk.
So it's soda, and tea,
and all of those things.
This table is horrible,
but this paper
was published in a obscure
journal many years ago.
This is just a scan of that.
There's nothing
else I could find.
There's no electronic
version, et cetera.
What you're looking for is the
effect of a boy versus a girl,
so number of males
between zero and four,
versus the number of females
and the effect of that on
the consumption of beverages.
And the answer is it
has no effect, that
what's in the bracket
is the tea statistic.
The tea statistic is zero.
Both the numbers are zero.
And that's basically
what you find.
You see what you'd
expect, which is
that, for example, when a child
is born, you're just poorer.
So you buy less
rice, less wheat.
But there's no difference
between girls and boys.
Boys and girls have the same
effect, if anything, on both.
Basically there's no evidence
that when boy child is born,
families cut back more than
when a girl child is born.
We don't find any evidence.
And this will be looked
in many countries.
So another tradition
story is the following.
Imagine that tradition is
when the child gets sick,
do I take it to the hospital?
And with the boy, the
tradition is I always
take it to the hospital.
With a girl, I just
give her some water
and generally sing
songs to her, but I
don't take her to the
hospital, something like that.
Do we see any evidence of this?
So this is hard to study,
because we don't actually
observe that many episodes
of life-threatening diseases.
But there's a nice fact
that Elaina Rose identified,
which is the following.
Over time, different
parts of India
have droughts at
different points of time.
So some areas have
droughts in 2006.
Some have droughts in 2004.
Some have droughts in 1996.
So a drought is a time
of economic stress.
What's a drought?
Why is it economic stress?
AUDIENCE: Lower end
qualities to low crop yield.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, basically
you can't grow anything.
It's too dry.
So when the rains
fail, crops fail.
Families have no money.
Well, how are they dealing
with this particular emergency?
And there she
finds some evidence
that relative to non-drought
years, in drought years,
girls die more.
So that suggests
that emergencies
might be a part of the story.
In emergencies, girls
are not treated as well.
So I gave one example, which is
not taking her to the hospital.
The other one might be,
when I don't have money,
I don't buy food for her.
So some tradition of that
kind might explain it.
Problem is that droughts
are not frequent enough.
And remember the trends.
The trends are all bad.
They're all getting worse.
India and China
are getting richer.
The dependence on
agriculture in general,
these kinds of extreme
events, is just going down.
Droughts don't matter
as much in India now.
30 years ago, agriculture
was 50% of GDP.
Now it's 25% of GDP.
So basically, droughts
matter less to people.
And since droughts
matter less to people,
you would imagine the
trend being favorable
rather than against.
Think of China.
Most people are now in industry.
They're also richer.
And as you get richer, and you
would imagine that emergencies
are less serious.
Because you always
have some money.
You're no longer at the
margin of starvation.
So the problem
with this story is
that it's just inconsistent with
the fact the things are getting
worse over time.
You would think that
under this story
things would be getting better,
because it's an emergency
story.
And as countries get richer
and less exposed to risk,
you would see less and
less of this, rather than
more and more.
So that's why this can't
be the whole explanation.
It could be a piece of it.
So going back to our
distinction between kind
of the tradition-based stories
and the more economic stories,
here is an economic
fact, which is striking.
So in other words, what I
mean by an economic story
is that tradition-based
stories say
that there's some rule
people use, fixed rule.
They have not
decided on this rule.
This is given to them.
And that rule somehow,
under some circumstances,
has bad outcome for girls.
So when the girl is sick, you
don't take her to the hospital.
That's a rule.
We're now asking a question,
when the economic incentives
to treat girls better changes,
do you treat them better?
That suggests that you
don't have a fixed rule.
You're actually behaving
in a rational way,
quote unquote "rational way."
You're actually planning to
have bad things happen to girls.
So do you see what
the distinction
is between tradition-based
stories and economic stories?
Economic stories are
ones which essentially
say that we are making active
choices which have consequences
for girls, rather than this
is a rule we use and sometimes
bad things happen, because
we use a particular rule.
Here is a nice example.
So in China, after 1979,
agriculture is liberalized,
meaning people are
allowed to keep the money
from going their crops.
This is the start of
China's economic miracle.
It's called the family
responsibility system,
and it's sort of when
everything in China starts.
Tea is one crop where women
have a comparative advantage
and even absolute advantage.
Tea is something that has
to be picked very patiently.
The most valuable leaves in
tea are the smallest ones.
So here to pick
the small leaves,
you have to pick them
without bruising them.
If the leaf is bruised,
the price goes down.
The best leaf teas, like
Chinese teas, sell for $600
a kilogram, so something
of the order of magnitude.
It's pretty expensive.
So if you actually
have the best teas,
you bruise a leaf,
that costs money.
So you better have
somebody who picks
with very delicate fingers.
Whether it's true or
not, I don't know,
but it's believed
in China that women
are better for picking
expensive tea leaves.
Maybe they are.
Maybe this is a story that men
made up to make them do it.
But whatever the explanation,
this is the belief.
So given that
belief, what matters
is what people believe here.
Because would imagine
that another crop, which
is the opposite, is fruits.
Fruits need someone to
climb a tree and pick them.
And again in China,
the belief is that men
are better at climbing trees--
maybe again false.
So men are better
at picking fruits.
Women are better at picking tea.
That's starting fact.
At that's what people believe.
Let's start from there.
Now suppose parents respond
to economic incentives.
And what would you expect
happens when the price of tea
goes up?
What do you think will
happen to their daughter?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: They'll treat
their daughter better.
PROFESSOR: They'll treat
They're going to feed
her more, or they're
going to take her to the
hospital more willingly,
et cetera.
So you'd expect that.
And likewise, when the
price of fruits goes up,
you'd expect boys to
be treated better.
Now in fact, both price
of fruit and trees go up.
And that's a trend.
So it's hard to use a
trend to study this.
Because everything's going up.
Both tea and fruits
are going up.
So you can't distinguish
between these two.
But one thing you
can do is you can
look at areas which
are suitable for tea,
areas just suitable
for fruits, and areas
that were suitable for neither.
Now you can say when
tea prices go up,
do we see a bigger
change in the gender
ratio in the tea-suitable
areas relative to the others?
Or you can ask, when the
price of fruits go up,
do we see a bigger change
in the gender ratio
in the fruit-favored
areas than in the areas
where neither is favored?
So we're always comparing areas
where, basically, wheat or rice
grows with tea areas
and fruit areas.
Is that clear what we're doing?
We're asking when the
price of fruits goes up,
do we see a different trend
in fruit-growing areas,
relative to wheat-growing areas?
Is that clear why that's a good
way to look at this question?
What are we worried about?
If we just said, well, the
price of tea is going up,
what's happening to girls?
Well, the price of
tea is going up,
but it's going up over time.
If the fraction of
girls is going down,
we'll get a negative
association out of that.
Because there are
two things happening.
One is that it's just going
down for other reasons.
The other is prices
of tea is going up
for whatever economic reasons.
And I'm going to correlate them.
I'll find a negative
correlation.
So that's not what
we want to do.
We want to look at areas
which are suitable for tea.
That's where the
price of tea should
have an effect, should not
have an effect in areas
which are not suitable for tea.
So we're going to compare the
effect of an increase in price
of tea in girls in
tea-suitable areas
versus non-tea-suitable
areas, not compare trends.
This is basically
what is called doing
a difference in difference.
And we'll take high tea price
periods, low tea price periods,
and compare tea-suitable areas
and non-tea-suitable areas.
You look more lost
than I would expect.
It's a very easy idea.
Somebody else want to say
back what I'm trying to say?
Who's going to volunteer to
improve on that explanation?
I'm going to [INAUDIBLE].
Somebody [INAUDIBLE]?
OK, go ahead.
AUDIENCE: Basically
you're trying
to see that if
this does actually
have an effect on how
parents treat children.
You'll see girls treated
better in places where
tea is the cash crop or
something and the price
increases, versus areas where
tea is not the cash crop,
but the price increases.
There shouldn't be a change
in how the girls are treated.
PROFESSOR: Correct.
So we're going to compare years
when tea prices went up with
years when tea prices didn't
go up and compare them in areas
where tea is a plausible crop
and areas where tea cannot be
grown.
So the increase in tea prices
should have no effect where tea
cannot be grown.
It will have a spurious effect,
maybe, but no really effect.
It should have an effect
where tea can be grown.
So we're going to compare
tea possible areas with other
areas, when tea prices go
up versus when it doesn't.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: How about
we think about it
just like you have you
control population,
where the tea price going
up shouldn't have an effect.
And then you have
your non-control,
and you just take you data and
subtract your control from it
to see you [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: That's exactly right.
So that's another way
to say the same thing.
Anybody else want to
add anything to that?
So let me show you some trends.
So that's the basic fact.
So that's tea prices.
Suddenly in '79, you see stock
tea prices just skyrocketed.
That's the first fact.
Tea prices are going up.
Tea production is going up.
Second thing is that if you
look at tea versus other crops,
tea prices are going up
faster than other crops.
So other crops are like grain.
Grain is going up, but
tea is going up faster.
Oil is going up, but
So tea is the crop that is going
up fastest among these crops.
Look at this one.
Here we're comparing
fruits with tea.
And fruits are going
up much faster.
Fruits with other crops,
like grain, oil, and cotton,
and again, fruits are
going up much faster.
So basically, what matters
is not the absolute price.
The relative price
matters, because it's what
makes you want to do more tea.
So tea areas are benefiting,
relative to those other areas.
So this is a complicated
graph, so let's do this slowly.
Try to understand
what's in this graph.
So what's in this graph is
areas which grow a lot of tea.
This is the coefficient
in the regression.
So this is the effect of
having more area devoted
to tea in a particular year.
So what this is saying
is that before 1979, you
see tea prices are low.
In those years, if you look
at the fraction of males,
the fraction of
males bounces around.
But the fact that tea is sown
has essentially very close
to zero effect.
After 1979, the fact that tea is
sown has a much bigger effect.
So this is the effect
of how much land
you put into tea in a particular
year, so year by year.
So in that year,
what's happening,
in 1983, how many
boys versus girls
were born in high tea areas
relative to low tea areas?
That's always the exercise.
So think of one more percent
of land devoted to tea.
What is the effect of that
on the fraction of boys
born in 1983?
That's what that says.
So the main point
to take away is
you see a big drop after 1979.
So tea areas, the
fraction of boys born
goes down right when you
think it should go down.
It is when the price
starts going up.
So that's what this is saying.
Before that, the average
is kind of at 0.15.
After that, the
average is about 0.35.
So the fraction of boys
goes down after the change.
This is what happens
in the fruit areas--
the opposite.
After '79, fruit prices
go up also a lot.
And fruit favors boys.
The ratio used to be lower.
It goes up afterwards.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Are these
significant results?
PROFESSOR: Yes, so the average
is significantly different.
You're right.
Year by year, they're
not significant.
But that's because it's
a small sample of people.
But if you take the
average of these periods,
the averages are
significantly different.
AUDIENCE: I'm just having
trouble understanding
how so if women are better
at picking tea leaves,
the economics make sense, but I
can't see families consciously
choosing to have more girls.
In 12 years, they'll begin to--
PROFESSOR: Well, yes and no.
You're right with that.
But on the other
hand, it also sends
a signal which reminds
them, oh well, you know.
Two things-- one, you might
imagine that the women might
be more pro-girls, plausibly.
And if you think that
women income share
goes up in the family--
AUDIENCE: They have more stakes.
PROFESSOR: They have more say.
So that's one
possible mechanism.
The second mechanism
is just that maybe when
girls' incomes go up,
they just look at it
and say, well, after
all, all the women
are working these days.
Why not have another girl?
They'll be fine.
They'll find a job as well.
I can't tell what's
going on at that level.
But it's clear that this
result is significant.
It's actually substantial.
Final set of thoughts--
suppose this goes on.
Let me back up.
What's going on?
How are they losing
all these girls?
If it's an economic
mechanism, that
says that there is
incentive to lose the girls.
How are they actually doing it?
What's going on?
Unfortunately, it's all not
very nice, what's going on.
So two things are happening.
One is basically the technology
for pre-birth detection
of gender of the child
has improved a lot.
If you do amniocentesis, which
is an expensive procedure,
you can basically
very high probability
predict the gender of the child.
The reason why rich
areas are doing the worst
is precisely because of that.
Rich areas are using
this technology.
It's an expensive technology.
You spend money to use it.
You see in like the richer parts
of India, signs up would say,
would you rather spend basically
$100 now or $10,000 later?
The idea is that you're to
give dowry for your daughter
to get her married.
And that's your cost.
And so you should really get
ready to spend, whatever,
$100 now, identify her,
and then have an abortion,
rather than spend.
You see these signs up.
They're all the illegal.
Amniocentesis about eight years
ago was made illegal in India.
It's still completely prevalent.
And since people are willing
to try to have many babies,
they're even willing to do it by
using a much weaker technology,
which is a sonography.
Sonography, which is a
technology that is legal,
it doesn't identify the gender
of the child all the time,
but over 25% of
the time, it does.
And when it does, then you can
immediately abort the child.
So they're using
technologies to identify.
This is why this is happening
more in richer areas,
because technologies cost money.
And the poorest
areas are ones where
the technology is least used,
because it's just expensive.
So you see basically a
very, very clear correlation
between where the
technology arrives
and the fraction
of boys being born.
So that's one thing
that's going on.
Second thing is going on almost
surely is a lot of post-birth,
I think, murder is the
only word you could use.
I think unfortunately
there's a lot of, I think,
children being disposed of.
There are villages which report
to have, probably report,
there's a news report I think
from like the Chinese news
agency which says
that we haven't
had a girl born in our village
in the last five years.
There's a news report of
the village chief proudly
announcing that there
was no girl born
in his village in
the last five years.
So I think there is a lot of
just direct, deliberate action
going on there.
Now, there are many things
to think about here.
How do you stop it?
The government has tried.
It tried to have technologies.
There's a bunch of programs
around now, for example.
India has a number of states
where they have programs that
basically promise parents
a certain amount of money
if your girl graduates
from high school--
quite a lot of money.
So that's one way to
[INAUDIBLE] incentives
based on girls' arrival.
But it's not clear
how well that works.
Because in some
ways, it's something
that's based on 20 years later.
And you don't necessarily
think that people
are that responsive to it.
The other thing
you can think about
is is there any economic force
that this, by itself, sets off,
which will then
make re-equilibrium.
So one issue that
arises is what's
happening to the
marriage market?
So what do you think will
happen to the marriage
market in China?
AUDIENCE: Well, if
there are fewer women,
then each one is
essentially worth more.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
Dowry should go down, and
bride price should go up.
Why this hasn't happened
already in India,
especially, is that
men tend to marry women
who are younger than them.
If the population is
growing, and people
marry women who are
younger than them, then
even if there are
fewer girls born,
the girls are from a different
cohort, from a younger cohort.
So the population is growing,
so there's more girls around.
So that's one problem.
This force might
operate, but only
if population growth stops.
So it's going to operate more
in China where the population
growth has stopped than in India
where the population growth is
still going on.
As long as there's
population growth,
you're going to see this
possibility of just going down
in the cohort chain.
So you might imagine that the
price of girls will go up,
but it won't go up if people
marry much younger women.
That's one issue.
Second issue, so in China, one
of things that people are often
puzzled about is what's going
on with the savings rate?
The savings rate in
China, personal savings,
is historically unprecedented.
People save 30%
of their incomes,
as it is compared
to the US, which
used to save zero till
recently, and after the crisis
has gone up to 7%.
So personal savings rates
in China are massive.
So one puzzle people have
often been thinking about
is what's going on with that?
There's a very nice paper
which does the following.
If I look at areas which have
high gender ratios, where
women are really
scarce, are people
saving more in those areas?
Why would they save more?
Why would you save more
if you're a parent of boy?
So he particularly asked,
if you're a parent of a boy,
in China it's easy, because
people have one child.
So they're either a parent
of a boy or parent of a girl.
If you're parent of a boy in an
area where the gender ratio is
particularly bad,
so very few girls,
it turns out you save more.
Why would that be the case?
AUDIENCE: The price of a bride.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, you have
to buy your son a bride.
So people are saving more.
So basically they
suggest that people
are beginning to
save more in order
to buy their child a bride.
And the way you buy it is
you don't go and buy her
in the market.
But basically women have become
very picky about not marrying
into families,
which can't afford
to give their son a
separate apartment to move
into when they get married.
China has very poor
mortgage markets.
So you can't really take out
a mortgage to buy a house.
So the only you buy a house is
you borrow from your parents.
Your parents give you a gift.
So parents now, it's become
a status issue for parents
to marry this sons.
And the way you marry your son
is by buying him an apartment
when he gets married.
So if you don't
have enough wealth,
you can't buy an apartment.
And then your son
can't get married.
So this seems to be sort
of one of the facts that
might actually
re-equilibriate China,
because it seems
like one thing that's
going on in China right now
is this massive increase
in savings.
The problem with this
method in increasing savings
is it's a zero sum game.
There are only so many girls.
So the fact that I'm saving
a lot for my son just
means my son can have a
bride, but not anybody else.
It's not now that the number of
women go up because they save.
So this is not really
solving the problem.
It's squeezing parents.
So if I were to save $1 more in
order to buy my son a house so
he can get married,
then somebody else
is going to want to
do the same thing.
He's going to try to
save even more than me
and buy a house for his son.
So that competition is a very
kind of a negative competition.
Everybody's getting hurt
by that competition.
So that should make parents
really rethink this strategy.
The one sign of hope
I see is this one,
which is the market forces
seem to be kind of operating
to make this problem better.
That's true in China, much less
true in India, because India's
population is growing.
So there's still this
minimizing of adjustment.
OK, so questions,
comments, before we stop?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: In China, what you
see about the increase in girls
again, because parents
see that they don't have
to save money to have a girl?
PROFESSOR: So you
might see that.
You aren't seeing it yet.
But maybe once it gets clear
that your daughter gets
to live in a wonderful
apartment, et cetera,
and having a son is a huge pain
because you have to now find
ways to pay for
his apartment, you
might start
preferring daughters.
So maybe we'll see that.
OK, thank you.